hi
everyone victor o'lachlan and sartre
pattineau here
representing bank of new york mellon's
clearance and collateral management
business
excited to present what we've learned
from our journey
in helping solve a key financial
services
challenge that has the potential to
bring big time benefits
to our clients and the us treasury
market as a whole
all realized by leveraging google
cloud's powerful data science platform
as the global digital business leader
for clearance and collateral management
leveraging data through analytics and
machine learning
is a key focus area for our business in
order to enhance our ability to improve
the client experience
whether it's predicting a failed
transaction or
offering a prescriptive analytics
solution to resolve
it our future is firmly planted and
operating as a data first company
bny melon has a long history of serving
our clients
as a cio of clearance and collateral
my responsibility is to focus
on growing this business but it is
important for us to know
how we got here and how the business
grew
to where it is today it will share
the importance of this exciting new
service that we are building
it actually starts with the average
investor
who for example saves into a 401k
if the investor rebalances her 401k
account
shifting from equities in favor of bonds
then
her 401k administrator may get those
bonds
by contacting their trading desk who in
turn
goes to the bond market and says i'd
like to buy
treasury bond a b c for 95
of the face value buyer and seller named
eb make their offers
and a trade is arranged the buyer and
seller
agree to swap the bond for cash
and they notify a third-party service
provider
of the agreement because they want that
service provider
to manage the actual exchange of bond
for cash
at the end of the day
the fund admin will agree to many such
trades throughout the day
in most cases that exchange is
successfully completed
but sometimes it's not
a counterparty may not be able to
deliver the bond
due to some unforeseen event occurring
after the agreement
but the investor still needs their bond
the fund admin keeps some extra on hand
to make the investor whole
in case of a settlement fail how many
extra
should the admin keep well that depends
on how often a settlement of failure
occurs
if the admin knew that they could
right-size their stockpile
and free up valuable cash
this cash could improve market liquidity
by buying and selling more bonds or
fund the development of new services for
the investor
so predicting settlement fails is key
but that would require a total view of
the market
the fund admin doesn't have that but the
clearing and settlement service does
b y melon is that clearing and
settlement service
because we're in the center of the
market we have a total
market view and with that view
plus google cloud's powerful analytics
we can predict which trades will fail to
settle
allowing the admin to predict how many
spare treasuries to keep on hand
of course being why malin didn't begin
in the cloud era
we had a 236-year head start
in 1784 we were founded by then u.s
treasurer alexander hamilton some of you
may have seen the musical
in 1789 the first loan
but to the u.s government was provided
by bnym
in the form of a treasury security
fast forward to today treasuries are the
largest and most liquid fixed income
market in the world with b y melon
still deeply involved in this market
clearing and settling
over 9 trillion in fed eligible
securities a day because of our
important role in the financial markets
a core mission of our business is to
invest in resiliency
and value-added services that help
create efficiency
and stability and helping solve the fed
eligible
securities fails challenge is a prime
example of that
so we kicked off of an investigation or
what we call
formed a hypothesis into how we might
help
predict these settlement fails the fails
vary from day to day
but generally they amount to one to two
percent of approximately
4.5 trillion in security deliveries
this percentage seems like a small
number and it is
but due to the sheer size of this market
it amounts to approximately 70 billion
of settlement fails a day
transactions that do not successfully
settle by 3 pm
eastern standard time each day are
considered fails
so we aim to predict the fails at 1 15
pm each day
providing approximately two hours notice
sartok can you tell us how we went about
this
there are four stages to our machine
learning process
stage one is focused on data ingestion
where we built a data pipeline to move
data
from our on-prem transactional system to
our on-prem data lake
all the way to google cloud storage
in the second stage we have focused on
data preparation
the first part of it is ensuring good
data quality controls
and the second part of it is feature
engineering
in the feature engineering step we start
off with
transactional information things like
account security information and
transactional information
and then we iterate across a multi
functional group try to get more
information
from the clients from the business from
products
from developers as well as from the data
engineers
at the end of multiple iterations we
landed up with 51 variables
44 of them were something that we
identified as part of those iterations
and most of these variables were
economic in nature
things like demand supply variables
liquidity variables and transaction
velocity variables
the third stage is around model building
and when we are building the model we
were targeting three objective functions
one
accuracy second performance
and third interpretability and we
evaluated a whole plethora of models
from simple regression to tree based
models
all the way to neural net as we iterated
over the models
we did finally settle with the light gbm
model
and the reason for that is the balance
between accuracy and interpretability
our clients were very interested to use
a model
which provides them directionality as to
why
a transaction has a higher chance of
failure than another transaction
the fourth stage is building the
production pipeline
once we built a model which which we
train and test
having an automation to take the output
of the model the output coefficients
into a production system and ensuring
that that is seamless was critical for
our success
also important was the frequency as we
retrained the model
every three months and also
going through the model validation to
ensure that the model
did what is supposed to do what did we
learn
from this entire process three things
first is data culture
we are trying to transform ourselves
from a transaction based organization
to a data-driven organization and if you
think about data
we think about the five v's which is
volume
velocity variety veracity
and value veracity was the most
important concept for us because we
wanted to build
a solid data control process
and solid quality controls up front
the second thing we learned was around
our transactional systems
and storing everything traditional
transaction systems
we focus a lot on storing our inputs
and then we have our algorithms and that
we store the outputs
which is used for client reporting our
end-of-day
regulatory reporting but as a part of
this process we tried to store
information at every point in time
during the algorithm for every decision
point the algorithm took
as a result we captured inordinate
amount of
risk credit usage inventory
position and cash information because we
do not know
which of this data is going to be useful
for our next experiment
thirdly we realized very quickly that
the success of this project
has to be a mix of expertise from the
data engineers
as well as the subject matter experts
as we were iterating there were a couple
of sprints
where we had 95 plus accuracy
and when we went back and looked at it
we actually found that we are predicting
the past
so that was an interesting thing that
when your model is significantly good
go back and check your model
the second thing in this entire process
that we learned
was the concept of agility this is a
multifunctional team
and the goal of the team was to
have small experiments in a piecemeal
fashion
and have an hypothesis for each of them
and as we addressed
as we hit those hypotheses we move
forward
or we go back and restart with our new
set of sets of hypotheses
so for that to happen it is important
that infrastructure
is not your bottom leg and
infrastructure is an enabler for that
and the third thing that we learned is
digital transformation
this is not about technology it's about
people
process and technology together
when we build machine learning projects
those are not deterministic
these are exploratory these do not have
a requirements document a design a
development
and a testing process like a waterfall
you have to think about small
experiments
you have to look at hypothesis
and you have to iterate so fast
iteration
is key to our success now let's talk
about results
our target was to predict
40 percent of the fails with 80
precision
and happy to say that we are able to hit
those objectives now we'll hand it over
to victor
to talk about what's next in the service
thanks sarthik so next
is a client trial after approximately a
year of development
and testing we are now currently in the
process of trialing this service
with our key clients this includes
uh interacting with the service in a
production like environment
and evaluating the the benefits of the
service so that they can trust that the
service is
accurate and consistent as the client
provides feedback to us
we can seek out opportunities to make
client specific
model optimizations are there specific
operational nuances about that
particular client
that are required in order for us in
from a modeling perspective in order for
us to refine the precision or recall
in addition we will continue iterating
on improving the service through various
market cycles
for example in our line of business
month ends quarter ends year ends are
important times for our clients
and the dynamics of trading change
therefore making it more difficult for
us to predict settlement fails
but by identifying these different
cycles adjusting for the different
training periods
and looking at different model variables
we can find opportunities to improve the
model
during those time periods and finally
as we predict outcomes we can then
identify opportunities
to have prescriptive analytics
integrated into those predictions to
help mitigate the fails
which will then allow for our clients to
get more value out of this service
now finally we'll hand it over to
sarthik to just
talk about why google cloud
why google cloud so first i want to talk
about why cloud
if you think about this project the two
focus areas
were around scalability and agility
the ability for us to run complex
machine learning models
requiring high infrastructure
requirements
and if we had to do it on-prem
it would have taken us significant time
as well as it would not have been cost
efficient
so cloud was a natural solution for this
project
why google cloud there are couple of
reasons here
one is google bigquery
bigquery is highly scalable and
extremely performant
our developers and business analysts
used to run
queries on our on-prem databases
of two to three days of transaction data
on google cloud bigquery they were able
to run the same set of queries
over two to three years at a transaction
level
and the performance was very similar to
two to three days
on-prem the second thing
was about collaboration
this was a perfect opportunity for the
google engineers
and the bny melon engineers to work
together
both of us focused around data
how do we build strong data practices in
terms of
data ingestion data storage
data indexing as well as delivering data
to our clients
it was fascinating to watch both the
teams
come together and solve a business
problem
thank you for watching this and hope
this was helpful for yourselves
you